9 septembre 2001 j'ai alors 15 ans et
c'est le jour de mon anniversaire je
suis aux commandes d'un monstre de
puissance 65 chevaux pour à peu près 500
kg en termes de masse un jodel des 112
nous sommes sur le terrain de
saint-andré-de-l'eure pas très loin de
la région parisienne et je suis avec
jean mon instructeur avec qui je viens
de décoller du terrain puis de me
reposer il estime que mon niveau est
correct pour faire ce qu'on appelle le
vol de lâcher quitter l'appareil et me
laisser tout seul à bord
seul maître de mon destin alors ils
descendent et là je me retrouve tout
seul dans l'avion et je n'ai jamais
conduit de voiture
ma respiration et rapide je suis plus
que tendue je m'aligne sur la piste je
fais toutes mes check list est là et
bien là main gauche va à fond je mets
plein gaz et quelques secondes après je
décolle alors légalement à 15 ans j'ai
le droit de piloter dans un rayon de 30
km autour de l'aérodrome
je commence un petit peu à me détendre
mais rapidement je me rappelle qu'il va
falloir revenir se reposer récupérer la
vie en toute sécurité sur le plancher
des vaches en décembre 2009
je suis alors élève pilote dans la
marine nationale dans l'aéronavale et je
fais partie d'un programme d'échangé une
sorte d'erasmus pour militaire aux
commandes d'un t45 goh chok qui est un
petit avion de chasse de fabrication
anglo american je suis au large de la
floride
et là c'est fini le jeu del 212 fini les
65 chevaux
on parle d'un réacteur 2 tonnes de
poussée un avion qui peut monter à 1000
kilomètres heure et qui pèche plus de 5
tonnes je suis tout seul à bord et je
m'apprête à faire une chose pour la
première fois que je n'ai jamais fait
avant a ponte sur un porte-avions et pas
n'importe lequel lui ss harry est
roumaine 333 mètres de long 97 milles
tonnes de diplomatie 6000 personnes à
bord et une est en train de se déplacer
à plus de 50 km heure au large de
jacksonville en floride
mon objectif est
simple réussir à faire en sorte que ma
crosse d'appontage arrive à prendre un
des 4 brins d'arrêt et ça devrait
d'après mes anciens freiner fort si ce
n'est très fort alors moi j'ai jamais
vécu ça aux commandes d'un avion et il
va falloir faire face et je pense que le
mieux c'est de vous montrer les images
images de mon premier vol de mon premier
appontage donc c'est assez sympa vous
avez en haut à gauche ou à droite par
dont la vitesse en haut à gauche
l'altitude et vous voyez le monstre
d'acier qui arrive et là il faut rester
concentré concentré jusqu'au dernier
moment et on attend cette cette force ce
stress si on peut dire sur le pont
d'envol qui vient même saturé
l'enregistreur de vol vous voyez l'image
blanc donc là vous n'avez pas eu d'eau
diot mais croyez-moi je respirais très
très très très fort et j'avais les
pulsations bien au delà de 160 par
minute fin 2015
nous sommes quelques jours après les
attentats du bataclan et là je suis
pilote de rafale marine
un avion de plus de 20 tonnes 15 tonnes
de poussée et nous sommes à bord du
charles de gaulle au large de l'irak je
m'apprête à partir pour ma toute
première mission de guerre
direction le nord de l'irak l'objectif
est très simple aider les forces
spéciales au sol
cette mission s'est alors
l'aboutissement d'années de travail et
surtout une énorme responsabilité
il ya des milliers de personnes qui ont
travaillé pour rendre ce vol possible et
j'ai un travail à faire et je n'ai pas
le droit à l'échec
encore moins aux excuses il faut réussir
la mission aider les troupes au sol je
m'installe alors dans le cockpit
et comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
images je suis aidé par le patron
d'appareils tu peux nous en jeu gardien
ce qu'ils nous préparent l'aéronef
malheureusement une fois que je suis
bien bray les comme on dit attaché que
je fais bien corps avec le segec table
avec la machine il va redescendre et va
me laisser tout seul dans le cockpit a
fermé ma verrière je vais partir faire
ma mission pour chacun de ces vols
j'étais seul à bord
néanmoins il y avait en permanence deux
personnes que l'on pourrait voir comme
des passagers
l'anxiété et le stress j'ai presque
envie de dire que c'était mes premiers
follower alors anxiété et stress on va
regarder la définition le côté
anglicismes pour ce qui est du stress
réaction à une agression un choc
physique ou nerveuse
donc si vous avez votre téléphone
portable dans la main que vous le faites
tomber
et bien il y à du stress pour votre
téléphone mais également pour vous
l'anxiété qu'est ce que c'est
l'anxiété ça un état de troubles
psychiques causés par la crainte d'un
danger concrètement comment gérer tout
ça et comment d'intellectualiser bien
faire simple dans l'aviation keith comme
on dit qui pète simpl haine stupide et
bien face à un événement stressant face
au stress quand on a détecté en amont on
va être anxieux c'est prendre des
raccourcis mais ça fonctionne très bien
dans dans votre état d'esprit
moi personnellement en permanence j'ai
une sorte de radar à stress qui a allumé
mon salaire fait un scan comme ça en
permanence et dès qu'ils voient un
événement potentiellement stressant il
va le détecter il va me le dire et boum
ça va créer chez moi de l'anxiété et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il vous faut de
la discipline de la discipline pour se
poser une question très simple
puis-je avoir un impact sur cet
événement stressant
ou pas je vous renvoie vers dessous
l'art de la guerre et l'importance de
choisir ses combats et ses batailles
si vous pouvez avoir un impact à ce
moment là et bien l'anxiété devient
votre meilleur coach c'est grâce à
l'anxiété que j'ai survécu à deux cents
à pontage qui soit de jour ou de nuit
sur le porte avions
c'est cette anxiété qui m'a donné
l'énergie de la motivation la discipline
d'arrivée préparer face à ces mêmes
événements stressants que j'avais pu
anticiper c'est cette anxiété de voir
votre téléphone tomber par terre et se
casse et qui vous a poussé à acheter une
coque de protection
si vous n'avez pas encore fait je vous
par contre si je ne peux avoir zéro
impact sur un événement eh bien là c'est
très différent et il faut apprendre à
compartimenter je vous posais une
question de physique ou d'astrophysique
très simple c'est vous ce qui se passe
dans 5 5 milliards d'années dans 5 25
milliards d'années le soleil devrait
exploser et c'est un événement qui est
considéré comme la plupart des personnes
comme relativement stressant pour
l'humanité
néanmoins rares sont les personnes que
cela a fait pourquoi au final notre
cerveau à son petit de la capacité à
compartimenter et a décidé de ne pas
être affectée par certains événements et
bien à partir de là si j'analyse que je
ne peux absolument rien faire face à une
situation plutôt que m'empêcher de
dormir ruminer dans mon coin je prends
cette information je viens la ranger à
côté de cette image que j'ai du soleil
qui va exposer dans 5 5 milliards
d'années et je referme la porte j'ai
compartimenté et là qu'est ce que je
fais mon radar reprend son scan et
j'avance step by step comme on dit cette
volonté de canaliser l'anxiété pour être
plus efficace sous stress a pas chez moi
par une personnification une
dédiabolisation de ces termes quand je
pense anxiété moi je pense coach et j'ai
même une petite vision d' à quoi
ressemble ce coach on s'est peut-être si
vous avez vu star wars il a des grandes
oreilles les petits les verts il évite
un petit peu d'anxiété pour moi c'est
maître yoda
quand je pense stress est bien là je
pense à une force qui nous permet de
repousser les limites nos limites
mais à une seule condition si on arrive
bien préparé alors dis tu rates votre
anxiété et dites à votre stress que ce
ne sont plus des passagers gênant dans
votre quotidien que désormais ce sont
vos équipiers et que c'est ensemble que
vous allez pouvoir atteindre de nouveaux
horizons comme on aime à le dire dans
l'aviation
fly safe et merci à vous